suguenot on a évoqué va dans votre fief
le logo de moi le sud de la côte d'or et
la côte d'or en général votre réaction
sur ce département principalement ce
soir je crois qu'il ya pas de grosse
surprise puisque concrètement je pense
que l'une dure de l'ump et ses alliés
tentent est à part effectivement sur le
canton d'arnay-le-duc mais faudra delluc
rappelez vous ce sont quatre cantons et
demi qui était tenue par la gauche donc
concrètement qu'il y aujourd'hui une
triangulaire sur ce territoire que le
front national soit là où il est mais
c'est pas non plus une grosse surprise
dans le contexte même des
départementales bonne ça doit faire en
pourcentage 51% pour marie laure acquis
qu avec un foie ciel à 24%
donc le la gauche effectivement ne peut
pas se maintenir ou l'avait rappelé et
sur le canton autrefois de durban rural
disant je l'appelle sales blancs d'oeuf
par rapport aux jaunes d'oeuf d ascq est
un peu ridicule dire s'explique
certainement aussi le désarroi de bouc
de beaucoup d'électeurs a pas de
surprise non plus je pense que denis
thomas est très largement en tête donc
dans ces conditions il ya sans surprise
la deuxième tour avec la fraude à celle
qui est second mais la gauche et élimine
également de ce territoire
un front national qui est moins élevé
que ce que l'on pouvait penser dans
certains secteurs mais tout à fait je
crois que c'est bien la confirmation de
ce que l'union fait la force et que en
côte d'or on le verra d'ailleurs sur
d'autres territoires parce qu'on a déjà
quelques résultats
je pense que l'union de l'ump du déni
aujourd'hui sera probablement dimanche
prochain parce qu'on a vu qu'il y avait
quand même beaucoup triangulaire
dimanche pour ça sera en tête bien sûr
et gagnera à certain nombre de cantons
je pense que c'était déjà prévisibles et
montferrand une réaction